>> Tucker: THANK YOU,
CONGRESSMAN.
COUNCILMAN, RATHER.
BOY, GAVE HIM A JOB BOOST.
SECRET SERVICE TEAM JOINS US
TONIGHT, SO THERE IS A HUGE
CONTROVERSY ONLINE THAT I AM
HESITANT TO WAIVE IN ON, BUT I
THINK THAT IT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AND OVER THE PROTESTS
LED BY THE STUDENTS FOR WHOM ALL
OF US FEEL TERRIBLE, YOU CANNOT
IMAGINE ANYTHING WORSE THAN YOUR
KIDS SCHOOL GETTING SHOT UP, BUT
ALL OF THE SUDDEN YOU ARE SEEING
THESE KIDS INVOLVED IN CALLS
FROM VERY SPECIFIC PIECES OF
LEGISLATION.
IN THE ALLEGATION HAS BEEN THAT
THEY ARE IN SOME WAY IN CONTACT
WITH ANTIGUN MOVEMENTS, AND
THEY'VE BEEN DENOUNCED AS A
MORAL AND HEARTLESS AND HOW HOW
DARE YOU ATTACK THEM, WHICH I AM
NOT DOING, BUT IT RAISES
INTERESTING QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
WE MAKE OUR LAWS.
>> WHAT IS INTERESTING ABOUT
THIS IS THAT I AM WITH YOU 100%,
IF YOU ARE INVOLVED IN A
HORRIFIC UNIMAGINABLE TRAGEDY,
YOUR VOICE SHOULD BE HEARD, BUT
WHAT I FIND IRONIC IS A COUPLE
OF THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, WHERE THEIR VOICES
ARE MOST VALUABLE ARE NOT ON THE
COMPONENTS THAT THE MEDIA IS
PAYING ATTENTION TO.
SUPPLY SIDE MEASURES TO GET
FUNDS.
WHERE THEIR VOICES WOULD BE
VALUABLE ARE WHERE ARE THE SIGNS
MISSED?
THEY WERE THERE AND THEY DEALT
WITH THIS KID EVERY DAY, BUT THE
MEDIA HAS FOCUSED MORE ON A
TEENAGER'S EXPERTISE IN SUPPLY
SIDE CONTROL MEASURES FOR GUNS,
WHICH, TUCKER, LET'S BE CANDID,
THEY HAVE NOT STUDIED IN
COMPLICATED LAYERED ISSUE.
THEY ABSOLUTELY UNEQUIVOCALLY
HAVE THE RIGHT, WE WANT TO HEAR
THEIR VOICES, BUT THE MEDIA IS
FOCUSING ON AN AGENDA AND NOT
IRONICALLY WHERE THE KIDS --
>> Tucker: THEY ARE USING
THESE KIDS IN A MORAL BLACKMAIL
WHERE YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
DISAGREE OR YOU ARE ATTACKING
THE CHILD, WHICH OF COURSE THE
LAST THING THAT I WOULD EVER DO
AS A FATHER OF FOUR.
I WOULD NEVER ATTACK A KID.
YOU CAN DISAGREE WITH OTHER
PEOPLE'S OPINIONS WITHOUT
ATTACKING THEM.
BUT THE PRESS IS CONFLATING
THAT.
>> DID YOU NOTICE THE
DOUBLESPEAK AS WELL?
WHEN IT COMES TO THINGS LIKE
IMMIGRATION RIGHTS, THEY DO NOT
SEEK SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE
FROM PARENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
KILLED BY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE VICTIMS OF
TERRORIST ATTACKS, TO BE CANDID
HERE, I GET IT, THEY CAN SAY
THAT THE REPUBLICANS COME OUT
AND THEY SUBMIT ABOUT -- WE GAVE
THEM A VOICE AND WE FOLLOWED UP
WITH A SUBSEQUENT LAW.
BUT THE MEDIA WILL NOT DO THE
SAME.
THEY WILL GIVE THESE KIDS A
PLATFORM TO TALK ABOUT THESE
LEGISLATIVE ISSUES, BUT THEY
WILL NOT GIVE ANYONE ELSE ON AN
ISSUE THAT DOES NOT FIT THEIR
AGENDA THE EXACT SAME.
>> Tucker: PREPAY PROPAGANDA,
I GUESS WHAT I DISAGREE WITH IS
THE IDEA THAT ANYBODY WITH AN
ALTERNATIVE VIEW IS REMOVED FROM
THE CONVERSATION.
THAT IS THE PLAY.
>> IT IS ALL CRITICAL THEORY
STUFF.
IT IS MEANT TO MINIMIZE -- IT
WINS THE ARGUMENT BEFORE IT
STARTS BY MAKING SURE THAT
TUCKER CARLSON IS A BAD GUY,
THEREFORE WHATEVER HE SAYS IS
THEREFORE UNWORTHY.